[Music]
[Applause]
doesn't go patterson with a rebound the
raptors
a chance here oh king ross
[Music]
one point game
timeline kyle using that screen
spin move and to jonas
oh how sweet it is
a season ago he averaged eight
a game only durant hard and howard
here's bledsoe now driving denied by
lowry scooped up pj tucker
knocked away here comes kyle lowry now
on the run t ross goes in strong
every possession
all through the legs of hill lowry
nutmeg
and the dunk by valentine's wow that's
some play by lowry and again the free
throw just making their free throws
alone they could have won that game
kyle shot
that went to the top of the cn tower and
came back in
this is what it looks like leo wow look
how high that ball
is i think his middle name is when the
rappers have struggled no defensive play
right there danny green
got a piece of it the block nice pass
through the legs again
great pass eight and that's a third time
hey how about this deep end right here
look at this through the legs for the
third time
in this game kyle lowry we've talked
about this eight men booker
you have those two players at that point
you need to go find yourself a point
guard
as jb lays it up man notice that pass
how high that ball comes up through the
legs again and
see it came up above jb shoulders
good job by magruder denying ciaco
kyle deep
got it
bucket and pumpkin and getting his hands
on the ball look at this adebayo
there's no time on the clock you got to
get up and take this shot away
kyle able to knock it down and ibaka
with it here's kyle
kyle quickly into the front row to og
great pass that time by kyle lowry watch
this
this right here oh boy wild cat
oh boy they'll be talking smack on the
main line
[Applause]
kemper walker a rare miss for him here
in the quarter
lead pass kyle pascal oh
what a connection 104
104. he's got over 30 again tonight
maddie he's got 31.
hello gorgeous look kyle
lowry tough shot here's kyle
lowry
twisting and turning with the reverse
[Applause]
quickly down the floor a little english
on the ball trying to get the foul
didn't
but makes a great bucket to end the half
north philly's finest
okay i know you better than that
the only thing i ever see you put down
is water or green tea
and no by the way no call that's why
kyle extended his arm
all right chris meddleton back with a a
three-pointer middleton picks up the
loose ball
has larry off the backboard in middleton
with the bucket game in phoenix
and his pass stolen away lead pass
powell
great catch over the shoulder lays it up
and in and a timeout
just putting this right on the money
check this out what a beauty
here's serge shot clock down kyle's
gonna have to put it up
step back range his
name is kyle lowry
first foul in the last two minutes and
lowry
brooklyn doing the same thing racing up
the floor temple tries again
and it's short this time lowry tries to
throw a touchdown and he does count it
and the foul
seattle lays it in got hit quarterback
to a great
receiver he's covered but the receiver
wants it more
on point you couldn't put it in a better
position and ciaco catches
finishes gets the home spectacular play
and lowry acknowledged
marcus smart's going to stay up high
taking anybody
coming to the ball series on the line
adanobi got it off and it goes
did it count is the question
oh gianna nobi buries a triple
at the buzzer kyle lowry
over the top gasal just screamed in a
knob
that ball's gone i think that's win
and a great winner great shot by og ann
inoby
but an incredible pass by kyle lowry
over taco fall he's a slam dunk he's
played really well
double digits in scoring he's got six
assists kyle
banks it in because he's north philly's
finest
kyle lowry says the night's not over all
right here we go
kyle lowry to finish the corner
whole window raptors down
18. gotta bring it here to start the
fourth quarter